shot clock now down to 10.  paul the last two hoops dramatic  emphatic  paul fires up a three it's good chris  paul from downtown and that will do it  big buckets here in the fourth quarter  from the sun's clutch shooting  and the knicks down eight with 13.3  remaining  seven provocative points by paul  yeah he feels into jubilation the  devastation  that he's caused the knicks off the  bounce and the knicks finding out  why the phoenix suns have the second  best record in the nba  this was the dagger right there  talking trash styling profiling  well again devin booker he was the man  through the first three quarters at 30  points  but it was chris paul cam johnson and  mikel  bridges hit a big shot after big shot  here at crunch time for the phoenix sun  yes these guys were reluctant to go to  their pitch